hello and welcome to this video playing
cm Blue Eagle blue eagle
yeah from Italy it seems I have got
2,500 okay and I saw get some points
back from the cheetah then I'm had some
games goal I hope I got that back Kim so
I'm a Sicilian with Bishop to b5 chick
so line that of course I had covered in
my book usually with Queen e2 but here I
don't mind to go get one very much in
the style of them Rui Lopez a little bit
like a brayer well it seems that black
should be okay because from the purely
tempo point of view black is probably a
temple of okay
hmm I don't know if
[Music]
let's play a form
CEO black responds one at one point of
this whole line with Bishop e5 chicka
said when you get this structure you
quite often mmm play against people who
don't play the riddle pass with black
and this then it's not so easy for them
to handle it's just a different
structure than they usually have on the
board not entirely sure maybe Black has
some good resource that I'm not seeing
but I think I'm already quite
comfortable here the a6 pawn is under
pressure
and I have those squares yeah that is a
convenient convenient pawn structure I
think
you know let's see what he does retro
retro chess let's go here
actually not so certain my deaf one
anyway
Bishop g5 s probably Knight age five
we do a cool maybe just here
you
I wonder if this is an idea just trying
to take on before play for a discovery
you
yeah if he takes on c3 I wonder how I
recapture probably with the bishop
yeah with the bishop yes
you
to see have anything better than taking
okay just he retreats the Queen
YUM it's not like I have a fantastic
reply to that
ship g5
yeah I should there should be a bit
quicker here it's not clear that
mm well I think I'm going to do that
and now
might be six isn't actually so fantastic
that was my intention now that I look at
it here it doesn't it doesn't actually
feel so great
do we get
what do we get more here
this take an idea on before I don't know
might shift I I would know I should
should never take there
let's put this
hmm f 3 9 f 193 95 this is a good plan
it is just a very slow plan
mm okay if I go Queen age five
taking one of 70 unis said something
Queen h5
and it's just scooter let's just do it I
hesitated for a moment because d2 is
like an x-ray but it doesn't matter
after 8 xb6 his rook is hanging as well
so I can actually start with this a b6
and he has to go go get it just has to
what the squares and then I can take it
it's it's actually I have its I have a
check out g8 I only see that now
so um where is the wind
Knight f3 Knight f3 is also crushing
threatens night five with mate
plus queen g8 night h4 stuff so that's
not that's not going to
Sabu
you
nice looking at their cell mouth
Queen d6 I can also
take the bishop everything failed Sam
that that's that's made
you
takes Queen h5 mid now do we have a
smothered mate no just a regular or
simple one
No all right let's have a look there
yeah that's a very noble position for
this opening and yeah I played Bishop d3
keeping the tension the computer wants
to go d5 definitely possibly that makes
whenever you close this position the
Tempe I don't really matter that much
that black maybe has compared to some
some real ions okay I went Bishop d3 and
now went a4 that's a different approach
I'm not surprised at taking on d4 is
correct yeah opening this up because my
whole setup is a little bit slow so
something like this takes
takes tanks and c4 yeah that something
like that is fine probably and I'm
curious about before ever played this
right so I took only five the engine
wants to go d5
you know definitely there's some point
of that and the the issue here anyway is
that I can go eight five and fix this
weakness
why if he owes a five I have this should
be sorry
yeah Bishop could be should be five
Nancy for that said tremendous and very
nice and what I did not want I wanted
the same kind of thing but with this
yeah being able to be used for an
outpost but it's possible that it's just
not as good the engine actually here
gives c4 which I found remarkable
and it makes a lot of sense I mean as
often now if you think I care agree I
take it you know and then black just
uses pieces mean its development is good
should see to my casuals
Computers a little bit less optimistic
about blacks position but is
compensation something like that makes a
lot of sense and here again it could
have played c-44 dynamics yeah that
that's a very that's interesting
instructive moment i mean who can't
looks bad on general grounds of course
yeah just it's very very passive move
but the problem is sometimes you kind of
know where that brook a8 you should not
play with if you don't spot c4 if that
is not renamed yeah on your own agenda
it's not something that you expect to
look at somehow then you only have those
bad moves and then you play it it's not
like you want to play it you know it's
bad but you simply cannot just give away
the pawn and if c4 is just not coming to
your mind then you're stuck in this and
now my position is very nice
to see what the the emails I mean the
computer says that things were kind of I
was slowly gaining pressure
and yeah after 97 it's over you know but
the position is um very comfortable for
me I was expecting something like Queen
c7 or something like that let's say
Queen c7 and then ideally when math
ideally I do this this this this that
would be cool then I'm at the end having
a good piece on d5 against the whacky
piece there but I have to be careful
Queen c7 actually look stupid yeah
because I can do this maybe not Queen c7
this
I mean I have this idea and I just have
to make sure what blundering upon it is
better because of all the good house
boss
okay 97 is a bad move yeah Queen have
seven beds okay it's all plus plus a lot
yeah plus thirty okay in an idea three
I'm threatening 95 but she cannot really
prevented so yeah I'm happy I think I
play it okay I didn't make any
substantial mistakes and it was an
interesting game thanks a lot for
watching